imagine giving birth to a 1360 kilogram
baby that's practically the weight of a
small car but it's the typical size of a
newborn blue whale the biggest baby in
the animal kingdom when they nurse
calves put on 90 kilograms every single
day thanks to their mom's extremely rich
milk which contains over ten times more
fat than cow milk so calves can grow to
the size of a Boeing 757 by adulthood
sounds like a pretty cushy start to life
especially when compared to other hefty
newborns on dry land elephants win the
biggest baby award though winning is a
relative term they give birth to a 105
kilogram calf which first had to gestate
in Mom's womb for nearly two years
more than twice as long as a human
pregnancy clothes behind elephants are
giraffes they drop a 75 kilogram calf on
average literally mom gives birth
standing up so the baby falls almost two
meters to the hard ground but it turns
out that tumble is pretty important the
impact breaks open the amniotic sac
allowing them to take their first breath
of air next in line is the white rhino
although not quite as long a pregnancy
as an elephant babies still just ate for
15 to 16 months once they're finally
born calves weigh forty to sixty four
kilograms roughly the size of an adult
st. Bernard but here's the thing if
you're about to give birth you're not
actually worried about your kids size
you're worried about their size compared
to you and Shingle back lizards have it
bad really bad unlike most reptiles they
give birth to live young usually twins
that total a third of their body weight
that's like a human giving birth to a
seven
year-old meanwhile bats usually have
just one baby at a time but that one pup
is huge a fourth of their mother's body
weight that's equivalent to a human
infant the size of a 16 kilogram cocker
spaniel meanwhile horse foals usually
are a tenth of their mother sighs that's
a bowling ball-sized baby in human terms
speaking of humans our newborns weigh
about 3.5 kilograms on average or 122nd
of mom size that might not sound like
much but we're actually pretty big after
all tiger cubs weigh only one 120th of
their mother size and a red kangaroo
baby is a miniscule one 100,000th of
moms body weight that's right a newborn
Joey can be as small as a single grain
of rice and won't be ready to venture
from the pouch for over a year but the
world's smallest babies are story for
another time